telling a woman she should do something
is actually anti-feminist we're told all
the time from so many people what we
should be how we should add so the
question in itself goes against what I
believe as a feminist anyway
[Music]
like I know like the step one through
five but like to actually do it I don't
think I could like be confident enough
to just do it you know yeah I don't know
there are five steps anyway so that's
why I'm here like I have changed my tire
multiple times just shows that I'm not a
great driver but I learned myself and I
had to because I popped my tyre left
[Music]
there shouldn't be any difference in the
fundamental life things that we all
should know and I think that if we were
all raised the same there wouldn't be
pay differences like we'd all have the
speed all be on the same slate so maybe
I'll switch it to agree I actually don't
want kids but if I were to decide to do
that I would want them to grow up in
that environment where there's no
difference between you two you don't
have like a curfew that she doesn't have
or vice versa I agree with you but I
also think that we have like where we
are now we wish there was a perfect
world so we want to raise our kids and
say treat everyone the same yes
absolutely you treat everyone the same
but recognize that not everyone believes
that way like if we teach our boys the
responsibility that they have not taking
advantage of someone when they've had
too much to drink
I just think that there's an awareness
that you have to teach boys being men
and also girls like becoming women
[Music]
I just think that feminism in recent
years have just become extreme but it's
like the 60s it's like if you're a
feminist then like you're anti anti and
like what like you know I don't think it
should be an tired man I think we should
all be empowering men to support women -
right and bringing them into the
conversation and I think right now
feminism is like we don't need you right
do I agree with that but also I think
that women have been put down for so
long that we kind of need to go a little
bit extreme in the opposite direction
just so that we can come to the middle
because otherwise the men aren't going
to meet us in the middle well feminism
by default is sort of the idea to make
decisions for yourself and what fuels
you and telling a woman she should do
something is actually anti-feminist
[Music]
because we're told all the time from so
many people what we should be how we
should act how we should address how we
should communicate so the question in
itself goes against what I believe as a
feminist anyway
[Music]
here we go I think it's circumstantial
because I do blue there are instances
where if the mother is going to be
severely harmed by a birth that that is
where abortion would be okay in my
belief and I think it also the exception
also would be in the cases of rape but
all other circumstances where you made a
choice I'm Pro pro-life I think we all
should deserve a chance my life so I
definitely suck in my I agree with that
statement but I feel like the heavy
restrictions that are placed on it by
our government just dictating what we
can do with our bodies is really
infuriating and then seeing people who
have kids and resent it for the rest of
their lives and raising children that
they never wanted it's frustrating and
so do you think that those parents that
are struggling with raising their
children that they didn't have the
option for adoption or other ways it
depends like for a lot of cultures
adoption is not okay so they would not
be able to do that
[Music]
three-two-one Tastefully is the word
that i that comes to mind like i enjoy a
tasteful you look fantastic right that's
true if it's wanted it's fine but then
like you can't mind rehoused you know
we've all had like bad flirting
experiences but then like i'm thinking
there's a couple I've had where they're
like excuse me I sort of let you know
you're very beautiful please have a nice
day and I'm like okay thank you you know
I'm like something like that that's like
short and sweet and there's no
expectation I think that's the thing I
mean and I'm from and I'm from New York
so I'm just like automatically on
autopilot don't talk to me to look at me
like my whole life you have the cat
calls but you have like the derogatory
cat calls or I don't look at you if I
don't speak to you I'm Abbi I'm on all
these things but it's like but if I did
give you the time of day then what would
I be I don't think like every guy is
like that but it's just so much easier
and safer to just assume yeah soon that
nothing is and it's not a good way to
live obviously but that's just well
because then my question is is who gets
let in and how do you determine who gets
let in and how do you function if they
start the I guess relationship in a non
romantic or sexual way like if it's not
like a flirty it's just like you just
meet people places and they just talk to
you yeah I just want to be like a normal
person
well at the heart of it I think that the
me2 movement is about women that have
been in situations whether it's work or
personal where they haven't been in a
safe space to speak up or share and the
burden that's on us to protect men or
other people by not speaking what has
happened to us is actually can be like
PTSD it's like traumatic to your system
like I experienced going through being
sexually harassed and this happened in
2013 and I still have never come out
about it statistically speaking like the
number of women who are raped
there's exponentially more then who
actually report it so when I think about
the made to movement like their strength
in numbers you know when it started I
was like I don't know if I want to post
about this I don't know how I feel but
what it did do was it gave me the
strength to actually share with someone
else I like I'm realizing as everyone's
talking like the reason I'm not in that
line is because when me to was a big
movement I didn't have the strength or
courage to be a part of it so in my mind
it's like still there like if I I didn't
have the courage to be a part of the
movement and I still don't have the
courage to stand in that line because
it's almost admitting that I've had like
multiple things happen you know and so
you're representing all the other women
that feel the same way and you know they
see you and they relate to you on that
so you're helping other women by saying
that
how is that any different than saying I
believe that the world would be better
if it was run by men like if we're gonna
say that on this token we get that on
that token that's not even balanced at
all I think what my thought processes is
in the current state that we're in right
now then I think that it would be once
we get to the place where we are able to
raise our children the same way and like
women aren't afraid till they go outside
and like guys don't have like toxic
masculinity then it's like anybody come
in the country and like it's all gonna
be the same because we're all raised the
same but I think for right now in the
place that we're in I think
women have a better understanding of
that but I think it's hard cuz when you
have little boys that are growing up
that are just not even accountable or
nor should they be for things that men
their fathers might have done or their
grandfathers and then saying like women
should be running the world it's the
same thing we're how is that different
than in the 1950s 7 year-old little
girls were told men should be in
positions of power maybe if we had more
women in leadership in c-suite in Inked
in in congress like what if we have more
women in leadership period it doesn't
have to be running the world maybe but
if we just had more women and women of
color different backgrounds like if we
had more diversity in general and
leadership around the world it would be
a better place that's why I chose this
one too because I don't think it should
be one or the other I definitely think
that what it's only man run they're
missing the rest of society you can't
really operate the world or any
government or leadership if you're not
embracing the second half of society I
think the problem with what some people
think feminism is is that you have to
bring people down in order to raise
people up but you don't have to do that
like you can raise women up to be in
positions of power without pushing men
down and I think that that is a
misconception with feminism
hey guys I'm Kendra thank you so much
for watching that episode spectrum if
you liked what you saw make sure to
subscribe follow us on Instagram leave a
comment below and we'll see you next
time